well what what what's going on
well whoa Blaire you seen this what do
you say we're all gonna die over here oh
my god I love rocks
yeah gonna hold dogs you I want to hold
you hold me works every time
in this world there are things that
cannot be explained in the natural but
be not afraid for there are brave souls
whose job it is to banish these piece
battle hell Blair Brock dark pepper
demon big dealer the Reza paranormal
team know that the show is bogus what my
team doesn't know can't hurt hello evil
entity can you hear me is Patrick Swayze
there are you friends with Patrick
Swayze I'm going to put the baby in the
corner Patrick have anything to say to
me now when I sent you out to get
paranormal equipment this is not what I
had in mind things pretty obvious on the
main track
an APEC when I was eight this face could
make this a heroin if you had a penis I
would move to California and we would
still make it legal I would marry you if
you were dude how much if you can't take
my girl me it's a person Michael J Fox
no no come on give us a clue
there's been some trouble with Emily
sunflower luckily I packed my exorcism
kit
you got something in your teeth
hmm we're gonna get rid of this demon
we've got to know what it wants the
powers right compels you obey entire
stamen
[Music]
is that DVD gods don't exist
Damon
daddy
[Music]